Right?
Wrong.
(Gunshot)
Let's put a smile on that face.
(Explosions)
He did it very, very precisely.
I don't know how he resisted looking back
You know we were calling explosions and light weight material that the special effects guy was blowing behind him
I think he wound up with bits of cork in his hair at the end of it.
There are three stages, one is like... uh, feel the hit
Then it's like "ow mother fucker" then it's like get her
Action!
You push me harder!
One Jennifer's stunt double being a male that they filmed from Miami...
So I'm looking at him what are we going to do?
Butt pads... this that... we gotta' do a whole bunch of things with him... to have the same sort of body she would have.
We had gotten it on the first take, we did two more takes, and I said please can we stop now? because it's starting to hurt.
Of course on the fourth take I broke my ribs and bruised my spleen, and so... and then began the saga of the constant journey to the emergency room.
You've been selling big guns to bad people...
So I happened to get the stunt that suited me...
But yeah I was a little unsure about something the first time we went down and my coat flew up, and I thought "I have no pants on"
Hans!
Booby!
I looked at the faces of some slightly incredulous producers when I said I would do it myself...